the conservatives first announced they
were Banning wet wipes five years ago
then they reannounced it and this is the
third time it's been announced they've
consulted on it twice and they're not
proceeded with it so I think uh voters
even lifelong conservative voters will
say don't take Us For Fools
and they'll say to the conservatives
you've had your chance you've failed you
continually fail we want clean rivers we
want clean seas and you're not up to it
and I think on May the 4th in the local
elections I think people want to send a
message to the government they're Fed Up
of the crisis in in sewage and water as
well as of course the crisis in our NHS